hello everyone this game was played in
1933 it was played in Princeton us say I
was played between Albert Einstein and
Robert Oppenheimer and this is quite odd
as I do remember in every book I read
how Albert Einstein often said of
Immanuel asked her that a man of such
extreme talents like Emmanuel Lasker
it's a shame that he waits waste his
time on something as useless as chess so
I was very interested to see this game
anschauen is white and the Oppenheimer
is black we have e4 e5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 Bishop to b5 to Ray Lopez a
sex the Morphy defense Bishop 2 a 4 B 5
Bishop to b3 and as you can see both
players are are into theory we have
Knight to f6 Einstein castles and knife
captures on e4 and this is still ok this
is the old theory we have a rook to e1
and here Oppenheimer plays d5 we have a
4 by Einstein and B 4 and then RB 3
kicking that night away from me for we
have a knight to c5 and here Einstein
captures the pawn Knight captures an e5
and Oppenheimer doesn't capture the
knight of course he played the knight to
e7 just you know prevent any discovery
checks so 97 and here Einstein
immediately jumps into the attack with
Queen to f3 and here we have a somewhat
bad move by the father of the atomic
bomb he plays f6 and Einstein
immediately takes advantage of this
movie plays Queen to h5 check the King
can't go anywhere so he plays g6 and
here we have a knife character son g6
and the Black Knight cannot be catcher
as it's been from the Oconee once so the
H bone has to capture it or or to ignore
it so we have h captures and g6 and
Queen captures on h8 we have a nice 2 B
3 C capture some B 3 and this was a good
piece but I don't think he should have
captured it but he didn't mess up
White's pawn structure at least
and well this is a probably the most
critical position in their game as well
black is still in the blacks King is
still in the center and he should
probably do something about this
definitely an idea here was King to f7
and if Einstein would have continued
with his attack for example Queen to h7
check Bishop to g7 and if for example
Bishop h6 now with a double attack on
this Bishop then Knight to f5 would be
an idea and this would hold the position
somewhat for black even though white is
still better but after this C capture
some b3 move oppenheimer played Queen to
d6 and this allowed iron strength again
simply too much from the position he
played Bishop to e6
now pinning this bishop and there is no
way for black the defended this night is
still pinned and cannot move the Queen
cannot help with the defense of the
bishop so Oppenheimer simply king 37 we
have Bishop captures on f8 Bishop to b7
know kind of pinning this Bishop here we
have Queen to g7 now attacking that
night three times so rook comes the
defendant rook to e8 we have Knights to
D to c5 rook a to b one a five nights
the c4 now attacking the Queen and well
Oppenheimer captures the night even
though well whatever black plays wife
will still still who win this very soon
he captured an ID captures in c4 we have
D captures in c4 now opening up a
discovery on the Queen and also the
Queen cannot move as its bend so Queen
captures and e1 rook captures and e1 and
King to c8 and actually just captured
the night Bishop captures on e7 and in
this position Oppenheimer decided that
this was now definitely unplayable and
he resigned so a good game by Armstrong
and although I did say this was played
in 1933 and Princeton USA there are some
doubts and the authenticity of this game
as some people say that Einstein and
Oppenheimer's were about 3,000 miles
apart in 1933 when this game was
allegedly played but I haven't found
definitive proof of this so I will still
post it as such and maybe some of you
have some more proof of this was it
actually played or was it not so that's
it I would like to thank Peter Fulton
and Marco Leonardo Montenegro for
contributions to my channel thank you
very much I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here and thank all for watching I
will see you soon